everyone that wants to record is
recording cool so this is my class on
isolated pendulums um an isolated
pendulum it's like a normal pendulum but
isolated but
isolated um so you're traveling across
half the Ark of a circle with your hand
and your forehead is traveling on the
Other Ark and so it'll feel like an
isolation just sort of bouncier and not
going as
far um so from there we can a bunch of
hybrids because we've got a unit circle
like you do in an isolation or anything
else that you want to join together
so for the second point if you're doing
this pattern you can do an
extension thises your
hand
or versus the
playhead um and that'll create uh two
different timing and directions that you
can get into um so the one versus your P
head get the same time same
direction um or same opposites from
Top sweet um and then versus your
hand you get into Time same
direction um
or I think it's split up split up Bott
yeah sweet so there's a bunch of useful
transitions there and hybrids that you
can get into um another thing you can do
with this isolated pendulum motion is
Let It Drop and lift so when it's at one
side you're going to let it drop and
lift it up to the other side so the
bottom part of that will feel like a
c but just sort of coming to rest
halfway this is a really good drill for
getting that bottom half just right then
isolating over the
top this pattern has a couple of cool
properties so the hand is making a
circle as well as the poe head um and
they're both traveling in opposite
directions and they both meet in the
center um so it's a useful and kind of
quy pattern in that regard so to make a
basic hybrid you can join an extension
to either your hand or the poy head so
joining it to my hand look like
this turning to the P head will look
like this
and both of those have very useful
transitions as
well so from the
hand at the top again we have split Time
same
direction so you can get to a lot of
patterns from there at the bottom we
have same time opposites so you can get
into a lot of patterns from there as
well so those are the two timings and
directions to get into from this
button um first is the head
at the bottom we get into same time same
direction pretty common useful timing um
and at the top get to split time
opposite
direction yeah um so those are the two
timings and directions you get into in
that pattern um you can also join other
patterns together
like or isolation to make more hybrids
as well so you can make these kind of
hybrids you can also join it to the hand
instead and make these kind of
hybrids um or you could also uh join it
to just the path that your hand is
following or just the path that the head
is following to make strange different
hybrids that aren't actually joined
together but still make really cool
buttons or
let
together together
together stuff like that as
well um which again gets you into a
bunch of other timings and directions so
if you just pay attention to what's
happening at the top half and what's
happening at the bottom half you can
sort of figure out where to go from
there um yeah so there's lots of useful
hybrids that come from this style of
pattern um and yeah hybrids are good so
uh another thing you can do is have two
two of these at the same time can be
clapping GRE screen weers whatever you
prefer um but for one particular pattern
we're going to be doing them opposite
each other going to move one above the
other one get used to that and also get
used to it at the other orientation so
with the c was on top below um then what
we're going to do is at 90° switch which
hand is on Top push through then at 90 °
switch your tangent on top again and
then continue that motion to make this
pattern I think that's the cleanest that
explanation is gone that was really
nice um from here there's a lot of
useful transitions as well uh if you
give the bottom hand some more momentum
you can get to this hybrid and then into
an isolation and you can do that all at
once to make that kind of
pattern um to get back out of an
isolation sort of Let It flop and then
drop and then you back into this
pattern yay floppy drop fling drop yeah
um also because I I mentioned this 90°
thing you can also rotate this by 45°
and you get into Point ISO Frameworks
and still chases and stuff like
that which is really useful so from here
just rotate
45° and you'll arrest the momentum of
one of the PO
and get back into
[Music]
this yeah so if you just rotate the
framework you change what gravity does
to it and be able to get into other
Frameworks um yeah so I think that's
about it for what I've taught on
isolated pendulum so go and explore it
and
enjoy Tim Goddard yeah fire drums 1998
me to what's your name
Jason this is this is 2014